bonsoir et merci d'avoir répondu à
l'invitation d'hervé france ce soir
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
l'annoncent de la direction de sanofi
aujourd'hui
pour nous
si nous cassez pas une surprise
on savait déjà que sanofi ne l'est
certainement pas jusqu'au jusqu'au bout
tout simplement parce qu'on savait que
sanofi allait considérer que mais qu'il
arrivait trop tard
mais commercialement
parler de façon économique et
commerciale pour sanofi c'était trop
tard quoi donc sanofi c'est pour ça que
ça nous fera arrêter c'est
[Musique]
apparemment
pas et c'est bien vers le futur de
développer d'autres
pour revenir sur cette annonce quelles
vont être selon vous les conséquences
pour les salariés du groupe
c'est l'incompréhension parce que
jusqu'à présent dans sa communication
sanofi explique à qui veut l'entendre
que bunge et tillman
l arène messager contre la corrida
sanofi verrait le jour
c'est pas le cas évidemment ça ça pose
des questions dans la tête des salariés
parce que
normalement des investissements qui sont
nécessaires on a il n'y a pas que sommes
pas de l'image de ce coûteux l'aide des
amis de sanofi on l'a entendu et selon à
direction sanofi le besoin ne serait pas
créer de nouveaux vaccins corrida et
rennes mais d'équipé la france et
l'europe dans l'arsenal de la kz1 et
rennes messager pour une prochaine
pandémie ce que vous partagez ce constat
on a eu une ou
sur le sujet les chameaux fina n'a pas
été en capacité de nous dire que nourrir
des futures audi une action il s'agit ce
soir contre la police ou d'autres
d'autres virus à d'autres maladies sur
sur le territoire français
sanofi nous a dit qu'il fallait
atteindre pour y voir
concrètement aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
travail spécifique autour de cette
nouvelle technologie arn messagers chez
sanofi
sanofi a chuté
[Musique]
de 5
mais aujourd'hui force est de constater
que sanofi a pris du retard il faut
quand même savoir que l'actualité les
chants tziganes rappelé que en termes de
création novak c'est même sur des
vaccins
avec
sursis laboratoire pharmaceutique
appelle le marché
accédez sanofi
[Musique]
devrait arriver d'ici la fin de l'année
pour les patients pour l'instant il n'y
a pas
eu d'annoncé concrète là dessus on
laisse un film comique
c'est ce qui nous a promis
technologie arn messagers notamment
développé contre d'autres virus que le
coville est ce que vous la considérez
comme une réorientation stratégique
nécessaire aujourd'hui pour votre
entreprise
oui
c'est certainement
une technologie du sud on a très
rapidement une capacité de ford de
production ce qui a étonné tous les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
d'ailleurs alors bien sûr certes j'ai
voulu passer important par rapport à la
nécessité à la demande des besoins
de demain entre les uns entre les
techniques plus traditionnelles et la
technique de futurs et actuels km2 de la
reine ne s'agit on voit bien qu'un terme
de réactivité c'est quand même une
technique qui est qui est bien plus
efficace que nous noté nic un ancien de
sanofi de
socialiser dans cette course à la haine
et puis on parle souvent de la rn2
s'agit pour
nous il s'agit aussi utile
oui il faut il faut y aller par contre
qui les paquets à racheter des start-up
focaux si ça nous fait mettre le paquet
dans la gestion de ces de ses salariés
en interne il faut arrêter ces plaines
c'est pas des communes successifs si
petit à petit sont en train de nous tuer
quoi il faut se faire confiance au
soleil de sanofi ils souhaitent investir
dans leur savoir faire et il peut être
que
cologna littoral mais vous savez on a
connu des périodes sur dix ans on a vécu
des rondelles anisation organisation de
calédonie sur plan d'économies on a des
chercheurs qui ya quelques années on
travaillé sur quatre ou cinq sujets
différents parce que le sujet que le
sujet précédent n'était plus d'actualité
donc il fallait passer à notre sujet et
la recherche a besoin de stabilité
aujourd'hui c'est ça fait dix ans que ce
goût nos faux culs de stabilité à sa
recherche ou est ce goût
ce but chinois
merci beaucoup pour votre réaction
jean-louis pérenne je rappelle que vous
êtes coordinateur de la cgt sanofi